[Music]
in gotcha [ __ ] news submitted by
Casey's abs tonight of what he's been
working out a lot at home he hasn't I
guess someone noticed you have a deal
with him man jobs if you get a 6-pack
you want to know too much of our size
little appearance in that sense turned
the kettle on for you is that what we
call it turn the kettle on a popcorn go
that's the microwave go beep do you
think I'm like some freak they'll say no
of course yes oh you're shallow let's
continue
what do you mean shower you see my
record yeah come on let me not a deserve
it dude because the last one man faked
his own death tell police catch his wife
who wanted him dead
wow that got Marsh's twisted that sounds
crazy is he dating like a drug lord of a
wife now like why is he so scared she
tried to kill him
yeah maybe she's a Russian spy no no
it's like is his wife a drug lord like
is she the [ __ ] sister ping of like
us like she's ass taken where she for
real can like off him
yeah because I Jill was like I want to
kill you on my good luck buddy but if
she is like what the [ __ ] think I can
do it nah but if she's like yeah JK
party challenge you know how easy it
would be to [ __ ] kill you go walking
he trusts me so much like he's he's done
in five minutes like don't even the
truck that my spider instincts go off
it'll be fun wouldn't go on I'll be dead
I think what's gonna happen is is that
the only way for you to kill him is if
you don't tell him that you're gonna
kill him yeah cuz the moment you do he's
on offense mode yeah she's gonna [ __ ]
murder you before you even think about
doing [ __ ] to him I bet you I could kill
him first JK party like three two one
boom hit the timer and we run off and we
see who killed each other
I feel like what's the point to the test
airsoft game jakie party yeah kill yours
no oh [ __ ] it big he can't hide hey I
don't need to hide but I break all rules
mm-hmm we should I want to do that so
while you're inside of the house looking
through the people and see this big guy
come out I'm gonna drive a [ __ ]
school bus from the side or [ __ ]
break right through the house and
[ __ ] smash you that's what I'm
thinking cuz like I feel like if I have
a kid right and like the kid just
somehow ends up hating me which he won't
cuz imma be an awesome father comes up
and he goes dad I [ __ ] hate you I'm
gonna kill you in life
mmm it's on now then that's kind of that
is gonna be interesting cuz he's gonna
wake up and he's like trying to make
some [ __ ] to kill me and then he's gonna
try the lights and I don't have a knife
at his [ __ ] throat it's like too late
[ __ ] dead kid you want kids just to
kill them yep I know every time you talk
about your feet your kids beat his ass
put em in a beauty supply store or kill
them yeah you know this is the negative
scenario that the kid just turns out to
be like a serial killer so you got it I
can't control that I can give them as
much love as I want but if they're
Psychopaths or Psychopaths that's true
that's true
we are lucky that we're not yeah but
what I'm saying for this week is this
lady like that scary of threatening
where instead of just taking her head
head-on like you has to devise a plan in
order to get the police involved you
know I mean you were in his shoes you
might have done it differently but the
way this guy what size shoes does he
wear I don't know cuz I gotta figure it
out if I could even be in issues enough
I got to that feet I think this is what
hey what happened was he needed the
evidence that she was a part of
everything so he had to pretend to die
so then the police can get her admitting
that [ __ ] I hired that assassin
he did a good job exactly what effective
Joe Barton his shoes he wants to take
the wife head-on so I'm like I don't
know how you would do it but this fight
that [ __ ] there's legal hey there's got
wood there's gotta be something that
about like faking your own death that's
like not well let me tell you three
this is a boxing coach his name is Ramon
Sosa so you could take care of himself
yeah so he's 50 years old from Houston
Texas oh damn - um his wife Maria aka
Lulu Sosa she's 44 pretty to get a
little food from that that's that's
trouble her nickname after a wife has a
nickname that's trouble
yeah hi Jill kill kill Quan like where
did the kill kill come from that's right
it's cute cute little mujer she's 43
years old she's a personal trainer they
opened up a gym together it was pretty
successful
sounds like a somebody we know so they
got married in 2010 and then 2015 their
actual business started kind of doing
d'Alene they started having financial
problems could they arguing all day yeah
that's when Ramon said that they thought
they would work it through like any
other married couple because the he was
saying like their marriage was awesome
like he his friends were envious is like
how awesome his his wife was that she
would give him massages all the time and
they just had a great time all the time
he always thought that you get all those
Swedish massages from your wife they're
[ __ ] legs Porter II can say be man
you know it for them you're [ __ ] from
who spaces bow my bow so then they were
having problems they let Lulu served
with divorce papers and they thought
they were just gonna get a divorce but
then that's when Ramon got a call from
someone that he used to coach before
which we're gonna call him Gustavo well
what's his real name
well spring oh that is problem you don't
hear it was that well that often that's
my dad's name something's double-doubles
a dope-ass name though I had a friend
named Gustavo and Elementary yeah was
that what he called Ramon and he told
him like hey we need a meet face-to-face
because someone's trying to kill you and
he's like what he thought it was a joke
so then they ended up meeting and then
Gustavo told him how his wife because
his wife didn't know that they knew each
other
oh and so his wife contacted Gustavo to
see if this table could find a hitman to
kill her husband oh [ __ ] and so I get
that life-insurance money yeah Ramon
saying that he was worth more dead to
her so oh my god what an evil lady as
[ __ ] who's double wore a mic and then
caught like an actual confession or a
conversation exactly it was admitted to
go exactly yeah
and so he caught that and then they put
that took it to a police I'm going to
kill you she was trying to hire this
hitman for $2000 that's it yeah I know
that's all like what
well some people will rob for 300 so
dang so very specific number jump to
believe is actually a daring Black
Friday yes the linguist that led Lulu to
believe that he was gonna hook her up
with a hitman for $2,000
they go to the police the police and FBI
are now involved in helping Ramon set up
like his death like isn't it isn't it
illegal a wiretap for stole I think to
try to catch a criminal like this okay
like premeditated murder it was like
Minority Report
but like 2017 she got tired of giving
him massages there's a couple here
she looks pretty from that faded like
blurred picture perfect and then so this
is like she's owns a gym boxing coach oh
yeah coaches sorry and so the FBI said
Ramon has to be three days isolated he
can't talk to anybody or else it's gonna
come out that obviously he's not fake
yeah that and then so they meet up with
Lulu they show her these photos and she
ends up just laughing and then that's
when it's an evil villain laugh she's
pretty I thought she was black what the
[ __ ] right where yeah I thought she was
like like skinny black yeah I thought
she was like the medicate or some [ __ ]
she's pretty she's pretty that picture
is very disturbing so like this real he
was saying like he was shaking like so
nervous when he was taking those photos
and he was like I never imagined my
relationship would end like this cuz he
thought he had found the woman of his
dreams and then now at nightmares
full-on when you're dating a Latina
anything's possible you know that's a
cool job like you're like working for
the FBI but you're like a makeup artist
or like
or do they hire people from like
Hollywood to do this
you know ii mean like there's got to be
like a forensics making person yeah
that's true maybe it was an FBI makeup
artist yeah cuz you gotta be convincing
you can't you can't do that and in their
life manish its fake dude [ __ ] you you
know like this person is just posting on
their IG it's like successful makeup
yeah work to solve a murder hire wait a
minute well there's out just the eyes
leaves the freakin blood yeah yeah i
wonder if it is a Hollywood makeup
artist or detective Johnson what
happened so she gets gets caught and
then go to jail I just gets up washes
his face and he's like haha yeah exactly
she got 20 years 20 years for soliciting
uh yep let's say he was a bad husband
and he keep beating her up all the time
then is it okay to try to kill him or
did Gustavo get his two thousand dollars
back I know I know you got a little chit
wait who knows hurt I mean does Gustavo
get paid stuff that's the question we
saw with the middleman between the
hitman cuz actual hitman was an
undercover FBI agent fine does he get
five percent yeah like ten percent maybe
you like finder's fee managed man you
know what's funny here we're not
investigating the right person Gustavo
why the [ __ ] would she like what does he
know right if any of you wanted to kill
somebody right what are you yeah my yeah
but high right like why would you go
like is your shitty I'm not I want to do
it I would do it but we know that you
probably looked at the Deep Web I have
the I have the phone book
I know people let me let me look into my
[ __ ] phone book - get your finger wet
you ever listen I'm just trying to paint
the picture that is cold so those are my
old contacts he's a changed man
Steve yeah are you still involved in
that nah now
car salesmen okay never I'm a pastor now
yeah it's always I'm a pastor yeah
does anything like but where do you get
hit man that's what I want to know
people do go to a list I want to know
that well let's ask Gustavo deep web
what is the deep web and how do I get
there is the question the black market
you've asked that before we don't know I
heard you have to get another browser
you can't use the normal browser yeah we
got look like YouTube videos about the
Deep Web it's just scary is free feed
he's a decent human being is the only do
you can't even use the operating systems
yeah that's ability Linux or some [ __ ]
you know yeah I don't I don't trust this
cuz it's like the uber of assassins I
don't want to work with strangers I want
to work with people I have relationships
with people that I could trust you know
want them to rat you out money turns
people into just really weird creatures
absolutely like your way we're don't
have money first yeah more money than
you had before
yeah but that's not rich enough you're
the Tesla yeah goddamn oh yeah remember
when you got your Jeep I was like [ __ ]
you and I got the Tesla finally being
middle-class is not weird enough yeah
this middle class now like I I mean I
was like dirt poor like [ __ ] welfare
poor but now I'm just like I'm good
right so now but that's not [ __ ] you
money I don't have [ __ ] you money [ __ ]
you yeah well now get [ __ ] you money
that's when I get weird with myself but
everybody else has blessings around me
yeah right now I have cheap costumes but
in when you see me just the other day I
had this imagery that I want to look
like I'm going on African safari and
dressed like one of those poachers with
the [ __ ] he's got like a khaki suit
with shorts are from like the [ __ ]
1920s bro yeah hey that's what I want to
live like Indiana Jones
I just want to see the makeup artist i G
[Music]